foreign
foreign
if there is anything that needs to be uh
categorized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
thank you sir you can't ask that
questions
[Music]
multiple times that it was massive dumps
that led him to lose the election which
is just dumps
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here what is what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
past the election
what is going on here
dumps
dumps
big massive dumps
all right here we are awaiting President
Joe Biden who is expected to drop the
hammer from the standpoint of
infrastructure and say guys we just
gotta get this thing done like at this
point what are we even really waiting
for and by the way maybe you could
inject some bleach in your arm and that
would take care of it exactly it's just
guys it's time to do infrastructure we
gotta cut the uh what the Malarkey right
this idea is a bunch of malarkey right
so we're gonna be hearing from Joe Biden
about 25 minutes and
we'll see what he has to say he's
traveling somewhere uh where is it that
he is uh was it Pennsylvania as Donald
Trump likes to say no hold on
oh Michigan
Lansing Michigan no uh uh Howell
Michigan
yes he's in Howell Michigan so we're
going to be hearing from no Malarkey Joe
momentarily I do want to say thank you
to Ellen McCarthy who just made a pledge
on patreon or patreon of some say I've
heard it said that way patreon counts
twice so that actually already puts us
at two which is fantastic also big thank
you to Adam David Lee for subscribing
via twitch Prime and thanks to Jen here
for gifting two more getting us out of
the gate very quickly really like a
Clydesdale already uh at five and thanks
to Bowflex man who's been subscribed on
Twitch for 20 months really an
incredible achievement all right so uh
we are going to be looking at a couple
of different things here I have an
interview with a restaurant owner on Fox
News who sent Joe Biden a message last
night in advance of uh this
um statement this visit by Joseph R
Biden Jr we're going to look at a clip
of Candace Owens
saying that George Soros is well just
talking about George Soros okay you
probably you probably get the idea and
then this is a little different people
have asked me to give my honest opinion
about a streamer known as QT Cinderella
I don't know much about her other than I
think that she may have been involved
maybe in the POG Champs I was in
maybe not I don't really know anything
about what she does but I'm always
interested in learning learning and
understanding and furthering my
imagination and stuff like that so we're
going to look at that
um and then also I'm going to share a
little piece of very interesting hate
mail that I received I will read your
super chats if there are any right now
it's humiliatingly
empty as you can see but eventually we
will get to that I've got some
voicemails oh oh oh before I forget
I had two extra special voicemails that
I put aside and I meant to play these
yesterday and it's from someone really
obsessed with my sexual orientation
let's take a listen
hey David I have a question
um how many times have you had gay sex
in your lifetime thanks bye that's
extremely personal and also a little bit
disturbing
um and even though I've said before
I personally I'm heterosexual it's not
like stating my sexuality is not an
attack on anybody
um
it's just what it is it's sort of like
if I say my ethnicity is 100
Ashkenazi Jewish which it is I'm not
attacking black people Southeast Indian
or you know Inuit or anything I'm just
stating me right and in the same way
this individual seems obsessed with my
sexual orientation
um they also left another follow-up here
fan of the show
um quick question uh are you gay why or
why not and
thanks why or why not I have to admit is
sort of funny but I do think that this
is a very very troubled individual quite
frankly
um
yeah uh anyway so that that's extra
special that's really special and this
is a guy who's been calling in for years
asking me like when I'm gonna come out
and all this different stuff maybe he's
attracted to me I don't know but
that it is what it is as the kids say
these days and then I had one other
voicemail to play from our friend
Whitney
um so I was wondering why you don't move
out here to Los Angeles I actually did
already
because nobody will like yell at you on
the streets and stuff over here I'm
pretty sure like all day all the people
who run like the entertainment industry
over here are Jewish oh perfect yeah so
this is what's called philosophytic
philosemitism
um you guys can Google that and that is
um it's it's kind of a BFD on its own
quite frankly okay a few super chats
coming in would I support separating the
1.7 trillion infrastructure portion to
get it approved independently listen
I am open to anything that will get
something passed but I also don't want
to prematurely chop it up into little
slices if it's going to prevent more
from passing otherwise right I don't
want to put
it's not really the cart before the
horse I don't want to prematurely
self-cock I guess is the way I would say
it Casey says Town Hall soon 10 19 6 P
East sign up as a member yeah let me let
me here I'm gonna I want to remind
everybody about a very special event
that we have coming up okay we are going
to be doing
a live David packman show viewer Town
Hall where there's not going to be any
membership goal there's I mean listen of
course there'll be it'll be there won't
be a requirement I guess is what I mean
there won't be a membership requirement
um to participate to open phone lines
the stream will start and the phone
lines will be blown wide open like by a
big wind or something like that
um and it's going to be this is the date
October 19 6 PM Eastern Time October 19
6 p.m Eastern Time October 19 6 p.m
eastern time Tuesday I've already gotten
emails from people saying I'm
unavailable on Wednesday the 19th well
Wednesday is not the 19th the event is
on the 19th Tuesday from the standpoint
of weekdays I've already heard from
people saying they can't do 6 p.m West
Coast they don't get home till 7 PM West
Coast and I said it's 6 p.m East Coast
time so we're already it's you should
see what is happening with my email okay
it is October 19th Tuesday two weeks
from today 6 p.m Eastern here's the
important thing to understand about this
live stream where everybody's going to
be able to call in okay
it will only be streaming on the new
Pac-Man Live YouTube channel
okay it's not going to be on the main
YouTube channel
it won't be on Twitch
it won't be on Facebook's it's only
going to be on the Pac-Man Live YouTube
channel
youtube.com slash pacmanlive or
davidpackman.com pacmanlife
that's it okay it'll be streaming there
members will get priorities so we are
basically going to have two things going
on anybody can call in but if you're a
website member at joinpakman.com you
will get priority during this live
stream so please sign up we do have this
coupon code felony21 it's so cheap it
should be a felony it's only a
misdemeanor in Alaska Hawaii Mainland
off you know all bets are off uh sign up
at joinpackman.com coupon code felony21
you'll get priority on Tuesday the 19th
and just make sure you're subscribed to
the Pac-Man Live channel it's not going
to be on tick tocks it's not going to be
on Twitch it's not going to be on the
okay it'll be on the YouTube second
Channel people yesterday it was funny in
the chat people were saying oh so
basically you're trying to build that
channel up
yeah
right I mean what
why would I make the why would I make
the channel not to build it like yeah
it's not it's no secret
um it's sort of like hey are you using
titles to get people to watch the video
yeah yeah
I remember I had a like a debate or
something like that
um with oh what what was that guy's name
Carl Benjamin uh Sargon of akkad where
he was arguing I was using click bait
titles and I basically said I'm using
titles that reflect the content of the
video and are as interesting as possible
like no let me spend time making videos
but come up with the titles that will
push people away from the come on guys
come on Okay so
that's that that's the point there
I think that am I missing anything on
that no okay so yeah just sign up at uh
the Pac-Man Live it's free you just hit
the Subscribe button perfect button gets
you signed up
um
oh check out this this remember this bad
haircut I got let's take a look at that
oh I haven't addressed by the way yeah I
got a disastrous haircut the other day
because what happened is my normal look
at how much better my hair looks today
than in this video
um oh my God it's actually even worse
than I thought my normal person was so
booked up she's so in demand that I
called and I said ma'am please I'll go
anytime get me in and I could I couldn't
happen and so I ended up going to like a
barber shop
which I love the barbershop Vibe you
know I always used to go to barber shops
but it was a disaster yeah and the
different problems are one way too short
here
relative to this stuff just like I feel
like I'm pretty accurately describing
the problem this was buzzed relative to
this stuff they essentially gave me a
mullet like when I turned to this I mean
I almost have a mullet
it's absolutely disastrous look at that
um
so anyway on um Friday
wait when am I doing it yeah Friday I'm
getting it fixed but
it's really bad really really bad and as
promised I took care of it okay so it's
all happening it's all great and nothing
nothing really to worry about in any
serious sense over on the super chats a
couple super chats coming in Tristan
says media is celebrating like
coronavirus is over ridiculously
premature not learning from the past
tomorrow on the podcast the pcast I will
be addressing the covid numbers or
coveted as some people still call it
um
where the hell is Chuck Schumer hiding I
think he's with Hunter he must be
wherever Hunter is it must be the same
place yeah I don't know I don't know
you'd have to check with uh
somebody who knows about that sort of
thing okay let's get into some of these
other items that I have I do want to say
thanks to papa bear Kenzo as well as
exotau
and
um Paco taco
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at nine and over on the
website
oh my God no website members it looks
like one person's in the process of
signing up at joinpakman.com so maybe
I'll have somebody to thank in a moment
all right let's get to some of these
other Clips let's go first to
restaurant owner sends a message to
Biden ahead of today's visit
let's listen to this I'm sure this is
fascinating today Joe Biden has hit the
road heading oh this was this morning
sorry to the state of Michigan to sell
his build back better agenda that his
own party isn't even buying so what do
small business owners struggling from a
crippling and a Steve Ducey really
struggling to speak small business
owners
um just re he's got a frog in his throat
just all sorts of problems labor
shortage actually need let's talk to the
owner of Augie's Bar and Grill in
Madison Heights Michigan Steve halcroft
Steve this guy actually also does teach
a business law at Brown University uh
adjunct good morning to you good morning
how you doing I'm doing okay let's say
uh Joe Biden's motorcade just pulls over
in front of Augie's later today what
would you tell him that he's getting
wrong
you know I think the biggest thing is is
this rrf fund and and the way restaurant
Revitalize it revitalization fund the
way uh the way the government kind of
hand selected businesses to get funding
and and then didn't for the rest I mean
there was 28 billion in that fund and
there was 80 billion that was requested
so you know a lot of us just kind of got
left out in the cold so the government
picked the winners and the losers and
apparently you weren't on the good list
no not at all we were we filled out all
the appropriate paperwork we had
everything done we were at the top of
the line and then uh we got a number
until what we were going to get and then
the world just kind of got pulled out
from underneath us and and now we're
stuck the wool was pulled out for I love
mixing metaphors
because it's the rug was pulled out from
underneath us and the wool was pulled
over our eyes which also wouldn't apply
but mixed mixed metaphors I don't know
why I just love it with absolutely
nothing and then some of our competitors
got millions of dollars yeah we'll we'll
burn that bridge when we get there I
love that it's now going to put me in a
situation where if I don't have that
funding I'm not able to you know do
Renovations I'm not able to to pay
better wages and then my competitor down
the street might be able to pay now I
hate to ask this because I know it's a
very conservative question to ask but
why does the government have to pay for
his Renovations I mean what why right I
mean isn't that like aren't I thought
businesses did the thing and markets and
everything two or three times more than
I am because of that funding I was
talking to my friend Lee Lipton down in
Palm Beach County he runs a couple of
restaurants there and he said that he's
got to pay people uh double what he paid
a couple of years ago just to get people
in the door and often somebody will sign
up for a job they might by the way sign
up for a job does this guy have any idea
sign up for a job
uh it's like I know that that's a small
thing but most people who seek jobs
don't I just signed up I now work at
Nasa I do just you just sign up I mean
it's it's just a sign up for them work
one day but most of them quit after a
week
yeah and and a week I mean we've had
people work
I signed three petitions today and I
signed up for two jobs a one shift and
then not show and and I don't think that
it's it's not the environment it's it's
just
they're they're finding other things
they're they're potentially job jumping
for you know 25 50 cents an hour but
you're absolutely right I mean well but
then pay two bucks more and then
everybody will stick with you
just two three years ago our wages were
probably half and
that's not something you want to be
bragging about right listen I don't know
we were paying half a couple years ago
no it's I mean it's just impossible to
keep up with especially some of these
businesses that got that rrf money they
can pay people you know astronomical
amounts really um and it's just it's
going to bury us absolutely and at the
same time Steve you've got this problem
where you know we've been talking about
how there is a you know people are
supposed to start doing their Christmas
shopping right now because there's a
supply chain crisis right logistically
the United States can't get enough stuff
in it's stuck on boats uh people aren't
unloading the boats they're not
definitely Biden's fault loading the
boats it's just a vicious cycle what
about in your business can you get
enough food to put food on the table for
your customers you know we can get
enough but it's a daily task to track
that food down my number one provider is
constantly out of stock and constantly
not shipping me orders so then I have to
get on the phone and I spend half my day
calling this provider and that store
driving I mean there's times where I've
driven 20 I don't you know Running a
Restaurant is a nightmare I don't deny
that I don't deny that at all
um but that I don't even really
understand the point of this interview I
mean 30 miles just to get a case of
chicken because nobody in a 20 mile
radius has it and I have to have it you
know we're we're kind of known for our
chicken tenders and there's we're done
for our chicken tenders
oh man it's all tendys at this place
there's instances where I'm down to
maybe 10 pounds of chicken tenders and I
have to drive 25 miles to get another
case you know if Joe Biden pulls over in
his motorcade today you got to talk to
him about they need to have some sort of
a supply chain Summit just to figure
yeah to buy if a Florida restaurant or a
flower at a restaurant doesn't have
chicken tenders It's gotta be Joe
Biden's fault and the vegetables too
fresh vegetables exactly
um what an interview how to get the
stuff from where it's being manufactured
to the people who want it yeah it's the
manufacturing aspect and the supply
aspect is the worst it's ever been I've
been in the business for 30 years and
I've never once had to worry if I was
going to get cheddar cheese the next day
or chicken or I mean it's it's really
bad right now he should actually
confront Joe Biden about whether
American cheese is really cheese or
whether it's a process cheese product
and maybe we could even finalize that
debate well uh if you're in the
neighborhood do you have do you have
site at August
it's
augiesbar.com
all right good enough I hear the chicken
fingers are fantastic okay they're
called tenders uh by the way
imagine that you're known for chicken
tenders and there's this whole marketing
thing around these are chicken tenders
good chicken fingers bad chicken tenders
are like fresh and you know and then
Steve Ducey just drops on you I hear the
chicken fingers are great now let's just
look up
Augie's bar in Florida
I'm curious
um you guys think it's this place is it
oh I'm sorry no wait was it Michigan now
I don't even remember what wait hold on
Biden's going to Michigan where did they
say this one just hit the road heading
to the state of Michigan to sell his
build back better where does this go to
the owner of Augie's Bar and Grill in
Madison Heights Michigan oh Madison
Heights Michigan okay
Augie's Bar and Grill Madison Heights
Michigan
Augie's bar okay welcome to Augie's bar
they got a Detroit classic Square Pizza
see what they got here
they've got pizza pinwheels baked to
order breaded banana pepper rings
Bang Bang Shrimp Gulf Shrimp
fried Brussels sprouts
giggle pickles
baked hot pretzel
garlic knots homemade chips and salsa
you got your fries
burgers are cooked with either a pink
Center or no pink
tofu can be substituted for any Burger
tofu you think it's just like a slab of
tofu I've never seen that actually for a
option the Taki the Woodward
hmm
okay seems like a standard bar oh here's
the here's the CH so chicken tender BLT
and fries
famous fried tenders on toasted locally
baked Texas toast Texas lowercase and
its Michigan man I don't understand what
the hell is going on here
Applewood is capitalized but Texas is
lowercase
crispy tender sandwich substitute tofu
Nashville tenders
it's kind of a weird weird place huh
round or deep dish Square Pizza
Nashville hot tenders
and then they've got their Originals
here The BLT the auggies special
old world pepperoni smoked ham onion
green pepper and bacon wow it's very
meaty right pepperoni ham and bacon all
on one thing
all right so anyway the uh chicken tendy
supply issues do seem to be plaguing
auggies
so that is that
um I want to say thank you to
anirban bagchi for signing up via twitch
Prime also Madison 78 man
Jen has gifted two subs putting us at
13. very much appreciate that I see
people asking
what is it that we are doing on October
19th so I'm going to mention it one more
time
October 19 we're doing a viewer Town
Hall live stream anybody who wants can
call in
members on the website will be given
priority if you want to be given
priority and have essentially a
guarantee of being able to talk to me on
Tuesday the 19th sign up I would say
right now at joinpakman.com you can use
the coupon code felony21 for a huge
discount you don't have to take the
discount it's available it's not means
tested it's available I won't check
anything okay just check local laws
about how deep the discount is sign up
at joinpakman.com and then the live
stream is going to be on the Pac-Man
Live YouTube channel whoops this isn't
it
hold on I'm going to get back to this
Pac-Man Live okay youtube.com Pacman
live this is where that live stream will
be Tuesday October 19 at 6 p.m everybody
everybody everybody can call in and it's
going to be absolutely great
okay and yes members will be given
priority and in all seriousness you
should just sign up anyway it's a great
thing we do an entire extra show for our
members and all of that sort of stuff
okay
um Mr Feeney asks sir did you happen to
notice if there was a 10d pizza pie on
Augie's menu I didn't
David sir are you wearing a Patagonia
vest sir well we've got really a lot of
uh sirs here sir your wife is up in the
air this is a Patagonia vest not a
sponsor okay not a sponsor in fact it's
chilly I should really zip it up
um not a sponsor but I I guess it's a
Patagonia vest I don't even know I mean
I you've pointed out to me that it is
I live in Michigan it's a very meaty
place
I'm five blocks from auggies it's gross
and expensive
tofu Burger this is the America Biden
wants first mangoes now people might not
be able to get chicken tenders from
auggies what the hell is Biden doing I
actually got some mango news people
might be interested in this as you know
the price of mangoes a major major issue
uh up under Biden but a viewer named
um
they didn't actually tell me their name
sent me this from a Wegmans 99 cents per
mango that is a beautiful price
beautiful beautiful price and as you
know the the sort of news from the
standpoint of mangoes was let me see if
I can find this diamond and silk mango
Pacman
um here it is this is one of my favorite
clubs
mangoes
my bad Trump cost me a
vehicle mangoes too
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now calls
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango aren't mangoes
like three bucks each that's it I want
what to eight or eleven bucks that
sounds good even the American people
belong if highway robbery is what you're
doing that's right
my man goes back down that's right yeah
right about that the Wisconsin crowd not
identifying with the mango material
so I raised the price of fruit don't you
want me to be healthy don't you
anyway so here is the um latest Wegmans
large mangoes 99 cents each that's a
deal I can get behind that's an America
First deal for sure okay so that's that
a lot of strong very very strong mango
material coming in there uh thanks to
mini Bean for signing up via twitch
Prime very much appreciate that here
this just this cracked me up
young fessa asks if I'm getting this
right the town hall will be for members
only on the main Channel Wednesday
October 19th at 6 PM Pacific Time right
that's exactly right Young fessa
that's exactly where it's going to be
dressed just like Han Solo where is your
Chewbacca
really is this a Han Solo outfit let's
say
any second now by the way we're going to
be seeing Oh I guess I see what you're
saying yeah
yeah I guess I sort of am dressed like
uh Han Solo hmm
you know I actually have an orange vest
I actually looked at the oranges of
vests and found orange vests or where to
go and that is sort of like uh Michael J
fox in Back to the Future
that's a whole other scene that I think
we could talk about
but not today
considering his love of mangoes do you
think Cosmo Kramer would vote Biden do
you think there will be a shortage of
plums with red on the inside hey you
know what I actually this I this is
going to be a real this is a real topic
okay I'm not joking about this
very often I will go to the grocery
store
and there will be plums okay and they're
all dark dark purple on the outside
sometimes they're called black plums
sometimes they're not but either way
I'll buy this hoping it's the one with
the dark red on the inside
I cut it open and it's light orange
that's not the plum I'm looking for and
they sell the rare actual black plums
and these that are orange on the inside
all under the header of Black Plum it
seems to me extremely deceptive and what
I imagine is going on is they can't even
tell the difference as to what color
this Plum is on the inside and they know
people want the real Black Plum and so
they just label it all Black Plum I
think it's a conspiracy but if somebody
can actually explain to me it's not a
nectarine what is the difference between
the plum that is almost black on the
outside orange on the inside versus
almost black on the outside and an
extremely dark purple on the inside
and that only started happening up under
Biden that's a good point no that's a
problem I've been having for years in
terms of Plum identification
[Music]
um
yeah the dark purple it's a far sweeter
plum
Plum with dark purple flesh
let's see what we've got
what types of plums so
extremely sweet dark burgundy
right the moyer Plum is the common
purple plum purple on the outside
burgundy you could even call it but then
yellow orange flesh that's the common
one that's not what I'm looking for
I'm looking for the one that's extremely
dark on the inside let's see if we can
find it
um
Moyer plum purple skin juicy okay
damson's Plum popular tarte flavored
Plum with dark purple skin yellowish
green flesh oh my God no Elephant Heart
sweet Japanese Plum dark red to purple
mottled skin sweet juicy red flesh
is that it
Green Gauge green type small round Santa
Rosa blood Plum maybe it's the blood
plum
could that be what I'm looking oh let's
see Moyer Plum yeah that's not it
damson's Elephant Heart no oh let's go
to Joe Biden
or very very soon very very soon very
strong construction equipment thanks to
Dave B for signing up via twitch as well
as mini bean and then a huge thank you
to kismar for gifting five Subs total of
seven putting us at 21.
um
very very explosive uh explosive stuff I
believe Joe Biden is arriving yes here
is
I'm gonna mute this one
good afternoon everyone and good
afternoon and welcome to the
international Union of operating
engineers local 324 construction career
center right my name is John osika I'm
the training director for this
organization and for for Statewide we
have four campuses including the 560
Acres that you are setting in today
wow on behalf of local 324's business
manager Douglas Stockwell in our
membership I would like to first thank
our guests
the media and of course President Joe
Biden
oh delayed Applause
I also would like to recognize our
International General President James T
Callahan who was unable to attend but
sends his warmest regrets regards his
regrets oh my God 324. we have we have a
saying we build we operate we maintain
with over 14 000 members Local 324
operates the heavy machines that Propel
Construction
the roads Bridges buildings energy
plants pipelines airports and nearly
every large-scale project in the state
we operate the cranes the dozers trucks
excavators and countless other equipment
that is building infrastructure daily
building infrastructure takes investment
for our members it's the investment of
time to learn how to build things safely
and efficiently
training is the key to everything we do
this guy's doing great investment in
ourselves in our work and in our
communities
I've been a member for 36 years before
coming to the before becoming the
training director
I spent 30 years working in the field as
a foreman superintendent building on
building the roads and bridges in the
state of Michigan
I know firsthand the skills our members
bring to every job
I also know how much there is need a
repair
the infrastructure investment and the
jobs Act
is Once in a generation chance to
provide world-class infrastructure that
is safe reliable and more resilient
it's a blue collar plan to invest in
America and create hundreds of thousands
of family wage jobs build healthy
communities and reduce congestion and
gridlock
the infrastructure bill is a job created
Lifeline to millions of skilled workers
throughout the construction industry
contributing to long-term economic
growth and improving the quality of life
for Americans
most importantly
it's an investment in our country
the IU OE Local 324 has kept Michigan
running for over a hundred years
now we stand and ready to build back
better
with that I welcome the president who is
Paving the way
President Joe Biden
a mask
I might need that one of the wettest
we've ever Michigan
it's good to be back it really is
and John thank you for that introduction
truth of the matter is there's a reason
why
the American labor movement across the
board
has a single best workers in the world
because they're the best trained
I wish the American people understood
how much serious serious training goes
into being a union worker I really mean
it you're the best in the world
I was kidding someone said to me earlier
that uh I said I'm a union president I'm
a union a president of sports unions not
labor unions and uh someone pointed out
to me that I allegedly have your word
used the word Union as president more
than the last seven presidents combined
you built the country wow no not a joke
you have built the country
and it's great to be here with several
excellent members of Congress
Lisa slotkin uh Melissa you uh you don't
want to screw around with her she's an
intelligence officer as well so she's
forgotten the man so you know but uh
thanks for riding out with me and thanks
for the advice you've given me and I
read that sincerely and uh how we're
going to make sure that everything we do
here is paid for paid for and not a
single penny raised in taxes of anybody
making under 400 Grand
get back Debbie you're the best in the
world you and John have been so friends
of mine you've been for so so long
you've stepped in and taken over in a
way that I think is had to be
you've done an incredible job and I
consider you one of my great friends
thank you and Dan I uh you're okay Dan
uh
you you ain't you ain't quite like the
woman sitting next to you but it's a
bunch of Milwaukee
I mean I really mean it you're always
there for everything to support your
constituents and you understand well I'm
going to talk about a little bit later
the way we built this country is from
the bottom up in the middle out not from
the top down and you get it and Andy as
my dad would say you got good blood kid
uh and uh thank you for uh what you're
doing thank you for stepping in and
thank you for the great job you do
Michigan I also have uh it's also
fortunate how much you guys want to bet
some right-wing media person picks up on
that and says Biden was promoting
Eugenics by saying you've got good blood
Debbie and Gary are in Washington now
and to cast some really important votes
to keep things moving and of course it's
great to be here with uh my friend we
become friends an outstanding Governor
one of the best governors in the United
States of America and her lieutenant
governor who covers her in every way
both in terms of physically and mentally
in every other way you and thank you for
all you did to help me get elected I
really mean it thank you thank you thank
you look I know there's a lot of noise
in Washington there always is but it
seems to me a little more than usual now
a whole lot of hyperbole a lot of heat
and I'm here today to try to set some
things straight if I can please I want
to talk about what's fundamentally at
stake for our country now at this moment
I know it's an overused phrase but I've
been using it a lot we're at an
inflection point every anywhere from 40
to 80 years in America there's an
inflection point we have to choose what
direction we're going to go what we're
going to do not not Democrat Republican
but what are we going who we're going to
be
for a long time America set the pace
across the entire globe for the better
part of the 20th century we led the
World by a significant margin in
investments in ourselves in our people
in our country
we invested in our infrastructure and
our roads highways Bridges ports
airports and the arteries of the nation
that allow Commerce to function smoothly
and swiftly and allow us to generate
significant income we've invested in our
people and opportunity we're among the
first to provide access for example to
free education it's a reason why in the
20th century began to take off it was
back in the late 1890s we decided among
the first countries that we were going
to be the first nation that every single
American regardless of their background
and it wasn't at a time regardless of
the background but based on income would
have free 12 years of education
we invested to win the Space Race we led
the world in research and development
led to the creation of internet and you
know but then something happened
we slowed up we stopped investing in
ourselves America is still the largest
economy in the world we still have the
most productive workers and the most
Innovative Minds in the world but
we risk losing our Edge as a nation
our infrastructure used to be the best
in the world literally not figuratively
not for a while according to the world
economic Forum we write 13th
our infrastructure 12 Nations have a
better infrastructure than we do which
means they can move product they can do
so many things better than we can do it
we're among the first in the world to
guarantee access to Universal education
now the organization of economic
cooperation and development ranks
America
35th out of 37 major countries when it
comes to investing in early childhood
education as a percent of GDP think of
that
think of that of all the industrial
nations in the world
the Instinct Americans would say if you
ask them 25 years ago and say we're
number one
we are not there's only two industrial
Nations that are lower than us
a strong economy
we've uh we've taken our foot off the
gas
we've taken we just I don't know what's
happened the world has taken notice by
the way including our adversaries yeah
and now they're closing the Gap in a big
way so it's essential to regain a
momentum that we've lost and work our
you know the work of our time it seems
to me those of us hold public office is
prepare ourselves to be more competitive
and to win the fast changing 21st
century in the global economy things are
changing incredibly quickly
that's why I propose two critical pieces
of legislation being debated back in
Washington right now the first a bill to
invest in our physical infrastructure
and the second is the bill to invest in
our human infrastructure ah I'll talk
about both these bills in just a moment
but first I want to set one thing
straight
these bills are not about left versus
right are moderate versus Progressive or
anything that pits Americans against one
another these bills are about
competitiveness versus complacency
they're about opportunity versus Decay
they're about leading the world or
continue to let the world pass Us by
which is literally happening to support
these Investments is to create a rise in
America America is moving to oppose
these Investments is to be complicit in
America's decline
support these bills is to pursue a
broader vision of our nation and oppose
them and to accept a very cramped view
of our future
this isn't about two pieces of
legislation
it's about the inflection point I
mentioned earlier we are in our history
the world history
so here's what I'm proposing first the
infrastructure bill it's about
rebuilding our roads our highways our
bridges our ports our airports our
Broadband all the things
that need repair Our arteries
of our economy have always been fueled
by the economic might and dynamism of
Americans across the country right now
45
000 Bridges and 173
000 miles of Roads according to the
engineers Society of Engineers are in
poor condition surrounded by including
more than 1200 Bridges as the governor
has been fighting to repair here in your
state 73
7 300 miles of roads here in Michigan
I'll bet everyone in this room can tell
me what the most dangerous intersection
in this town or any town they live in
and where it is
that you hold your breath when you're
driving over trying to cross the street
not a joke
working with the governor and members of
the Congress here
we're going to put hard work in
Americans like the operating engineers
here in Howe on the job to bring back
our infrastructure and bring it up to
speed
good union jobs
not 12 15 18 prevailing wage jobs wage
that give you dignity that you're going
to raise a family on that you can hold
your head up
this is a blue collar blueprint for how
we restore America's Pride
and the jobs can't these are jobs that
can't be outsourced
we're going to put plumbers and
pipefitters to work replacing lead pipes
in America so families and children can
drink clean water
4 400 000 schools I mean this is it's
not just their homes it's across the
country
we're going to put line workers and
electricians to work laying thousands of
miles of transmission lines and to build
a modern infrastructure and energy grid
we're going to make high speed internet
affordable and available everywhere in
America we're talking about on the way
over well listen how short the number of
num the number people have access to the
internet here because of the the lack of
investment
we're going to make the largest
investment in public transit in the
American history
is the most important investment in our
Rail System since the creation of amp
track 50 years ago
let me tell you our competitors aren't
hanging around and waiting see we're
going to do
they've been pouring billions of dollars
in the infrastructure and into this
training their people for years now take
China for example
now I've been clear that China uses
unfair scores for practice to get ahead
of their competitors but that's not the
whole the story
they're also investing in themselves
in recent years China has spent around
three times as much on infrastructure as
a share of their economy than we have
three times
they're not slowing down yesterday my
U.S trade representative delivered an
important speech on our competition with
China she pointed out that China made a
major investment in steel plants
beginning about 20 years ago
in the last 20 years half of American
steel companies have been shuttered
we went from 100 U.S steel companies to
51.
and employment in America is still and
it's a drop by 40 percent
since the year 2000 China now produces
more Steel in one month
that America does in an entire year wow
you can see it in the sector after
sector other countries are speeding up
in America's falling behind
we've got to reset the pacing what's
what's kind of depressing about this
speech is that all of this stuff relates
to why we need the infrastructure bill
but for so many people
they don't know how this even connects
to the infrastructure bill and I think
the criticism would be it's not obvious
unless Biden's not doing a good enough
job of connecting it for people who
don't get it and uh GM I mean General
Motors Chrysler and Ford
you know and what have they decided to
do they decided they're going to lead
the world and they're going to build
more of the electric vehicles than any
other country but guess what China's not
waiting around they manufacture more
than twice as many electric vehicles as
we have over the last decade they
control more than 75 percent of the
battery Market
and they're poised to invest another 14
billion dollars
and charging capacity now
in their country
back in May the chance to tour forged
new state-of-the-art facility in
Dearborn where union workers are
building the first ever all-electric
Ford F-150 I got to drive that sucker
it's quick zero and a 60 in 4.1 seconds
and it's a friend of mine just put down
a deposit on one of those F-150s the
electrics I hosted the three the the big
three automakers at the White House for
the Ford 150 was joined by the GMC
Hummer and the Jeep Wagoneer all going
electric all in partnership with the UAW
the whole world knows that the future of
their Auto industry is electric
we need to make sure America builds that
future instead of falling behind
we should build those vehicles and the
batteries to get them here in the United
States of America that's what we should
build here in the state of Michigan
I want those jobs and I really mean it I
want those jobs here in Michigan not
halfway around the globe
that's what my plan will do the
infrastructure bill will put in motion
the union workers on the job installing
national network of hundreds of
thousands of charging stations along our
roads and highways and communities over
500 000 of them and by the way yeah this
is a really good point by Super Chat
it's pathetic the need to justify vital
legislation in terms of how we compare
with other countries right if our
bridges suck who cares if they're the
13th best or worst like if the bridges
suck we got to get better Bridges some
people that they put allow them to put
20 000 gallons of gasoline under the
ground they didn't want them around but
guess what happened everything builds up
around them you put these charging
stations along however you're going to
see a significant Economic Development
go well beyond the charging station
and the bill back better plan will boost
our manufacturing capacity investing in
new and retool facilities and employ
American workers with good wages and
benefits that includes grants to
Kickstart new battery and parts you know
what he hasn't mentioned though as far
as infrastructure goes elements of
bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers yeah now what's he going to do
about that and also what's he going to
do about people
a few times you should address it
look these are the kinds of Investments
That get America back in the game and
give our workers a chance
my plan also makes historic investments
in clean energy including tax credits
until people do things like weatherizing
their homes install solar panels develop
clean energy products to help businesses
produce more clean energy all told this
project will say literally hundreds of
millions of barrels of oil yeah but the
noise is cancer
these credits those credits could cut
the cost of installing the rooftop solar
by about 30 percent
helping families cut their utility bills
and helping the country cut its
emissions my infrastructure bill will
put America's to work and long overdue
National Environmental cleanups
I want a Job Corps just like Roosevelt
of a Job Corps but an environmental Job
Corps of over 160 000 this is sort of
like the fundamental difference between
what we have and a kind of northern
European social democracy
it those aren't they're not perfect but
in a northern European social democracy
you're not really arguing with people
about such fundamental elements right
it's like we've these are just must
haves everybody's got to have this let's
argue about other things it's going to
help us meet the moment of the climate
crisis and do away with you know it's
going to create good jobs making more
economically make us more economy
competitive folks here in Michigan
you all know the cost of extreme weather
all I remember the flooding this Summer
that shut down parts of I-96
the power outages and the tornado
warnings they're costing your state
billions of dollars
nationally last year
last year
because of extreme weather cost America
99
billion dollars wow 99 billion taxpayers
dollars
I went all over the country
I went out west to the fires you know
more is burned down in the Northwest
then the entire state of New Jersey
that's how much we've lost
you see what's happened with the
droughts that are out there
you see reservoirs that are down 30 40
50 feet
I was worried about the cooling down
you're worried about whether you're
going to have what the Colorado River is
going to do this is a big deal
this is gigantic
and we're not going to ease up
we're not going to ease up in any of
this we have to invest in resilience
resilience
you saw Texas their entire power grid
went down
because they had no resilience right the
ability to build back and build things
stronger why a lot of those fires in the
Far West and because guess what it's a
hell of a lot safer to have those wires
Underground
not be knocked down by high winds and
tornadoes and the light causing fires
look I haven't pressed it I haven't
passed them maybe we haven't passed a
major infrastructure bill for decades of
this country it used to be a normal
thing to do right used to be a
bipartisan thing to do if we get this
done we're going to Breathe new life
into our economy and our workers and
we're going to breathe cleaner air
economists and please remember guys it's
3.5 trillion over 10 years it's 350
billion a year inconceivable numbers
like for a household right but there's a
big difference here bills could help our
economy create an additional 2 million
jobs per year every year 2 million per
year
that's going to be transformative
and here's the deal
the jobs in my plan are people who too
often felt left behind and were left
behind left out
90 percent of the jobs
in this bill these bills and my
infrastructure plan don't require a
four-year college degree
we need to get this done
but it isn't enough just to invest in
our physical infrastructure we're going
to lead the world like we used to if
we're going to do that we have to also
invest in our people like you do right
here in training this in this training
facility your damn emails that's why my
second Bill the build back better plan
that's what it does take education for
example
when America said Corn Pop has not come
up titled 12 years of free public
education
Universal a century ago
it gave us the best educated best
prepared Workforce in the world that was
one of the reasons why America began to
grow so rapidly
it's a big part of why we led the world
the bulk of the 20th century
but guess what
if we're going to put together a
committee today like they did in 1898 I
think it was
and we're going to invent a public
education system
there's any chance we'd say that we
thought 12 years was enough in the 21st
century no
just 12 years
I don't think so
study after study shows that the earlier
our children began to learn the school
not daycare the better for themselves
for their families
no matter what the background they come
from no matter what their background
recent university studies point out that
they're increased by 56 percent the
chance to get all the way through 12
years of school without getting in
trouble
it's a gigantic deal
it doesn't matter whether Mom or Dad
know how to read or write or the home is
a home that is challenging
but right now we're lagging behind
while other countries are investing in
their children
today only about half of three and
four-year-olds in America are enrolled
in early childhood education oof this is
going to be France the United Kingdom
Latvia
the number that number is more than 90
percent 90 percent of their three and
four-year-olds
we're falling further and further behind
the curve
it's not just Early Education
according to one study we rank 33 out of
44 advanced economies when it comes to
the percentage of our young people who
have attained a post-high school degree
anything after high school
or the bottom of the Heap I'll betify
that was on a quiz you're on one of
these quiz shows I ask you that you
would have said maybe we're two or three
or four
it's ridiculous
my buildback player build back better
playing gets us back on track
we'll make four additional years of
public education available every person
in America
two years of high quality preschool at
the front end and investments in
community colleges so our students can
gain skills they need to carve out a
place for themselves in the 21st century
economy and also increase Pell Grants
their grants for kids making families
less than 50 Grand helping their helping
their folks helping them get through
Community College or a historically
in order the people he's trying to
convince think that all of these
institutions are centers of liberal
indoctrination so it's like you know how
do you convince someone whose entire
basis is so backwards to help to support
and to make sure that young people of
every background and Circumstance have a
shot of good paying jobs
look this bill also invests in our
Workforce
by providing so much needed breathing
room for Working Families after all how
can we compete in the world if millions
of American parents especially moms
can't join the week the workforce
because they can't afford the cost of
child care Elder Care they have to stay
home
for example here in Michigan the average
two-parent family spends ten thousand
four hundred dollars on child care costs
for just one child each year
30 years ago the United States ranked
six
six among advanced economies and the
share of women in the workforce
you know we are today
not sick yeah 22 countries have a higher
percentage of their women in the
workforce making competitive wage than
the United States
while my competitors are investing in
the care economy we're standing still
and the fact is millions of American
parents are feeling the squeeze having a
hard time doing their job earning a
paycheck while taking care of their
children or aging parents and at the
same time in this sandwich generation
my build back better plan is going to
change that is it cut the cost of child
care for most Michigan families by more
than half it's going to extend historic
middle class tax cut
to the child care tax credit which we
passed in my American Rescue plan now
most people don't know if you walk to
the average informed person doctor
lawyer or whatever and said child care
tax credit
they're not sure what that means but
what it means is you know if you were
making a decent the average informed
person like a doctor or a lawyer kids
are four under the age of 18 you get
anybody understand that two thousand
dollars for each child off your bottom
line in your taxes you owe
well guess what if you're making 15
bucks an hour you don't have any taxes
to pay like that so guess what you got
nothing
zero zero no help
my friends and other team have no
problem giving billionaires and
millionaires gigantic tax breaks
this is a tax cut
you know what it does is now and it's in
place and people in your state are
understanding it now
instead of it provides it up the ante
how much you could get for a child under
seven you get 3 600 bucks right tax cut
on a yearly basis
and you get 3 000 for a child under 17.
but guess what we did
that means we're doing it on a monthly
basis now
it means you're getting either 300 a
month or 200 a month just like your
social security check at home
it's cut child poverty in by 40 percent
that money is already a life changer for
so many Working Families
and as I said that's actually I was
wrong in Michigan is 44 cut in child
poverty we need to keep it going
my plan is going to put America's work
constructing the rehabilitating safe and
affordable housing to help ease the cost
of housing I'll generate even more jobs
and most of the major metropolitan areas
in America there you can't afford the
housing
and it helps to meet the moment on
climate change as well
we're setting the course for America to
achieve 50 to 52 percent reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions wow 2030.
for us to read next to reach net zero
emissions by 2050.
this bill helps us get there in a way
that creates good jobs makes us global
leaders of fast growing clean energy
Industries like electric vehicles solar
and wind power battery power
the bottom line is this
when we give Working Families a break
we're not just raising their quality of
life
we're putting parents in a position to
earn a paycheck
we're also positioning our country to
compete in the world
that's what these bills are all about
if you want proof just come to this
training facility
this is where hard-working folks come to
learn how to operate road graders and so
much more
where workers use Virtual Reality to
master operating in a crane
and learn how to deal with drones and
look underneath Bridges and so on
or young people in Michigan show up and
emerge as expert technicians Engineers
heavy equipment operators
they leave here with a shot at something
great a union job with good wages and
benefits that allow them to maintain
their dignity and their pride
it's a ticket to the middle class
this is where the economy starts with
you your skills your dreams and your
Limitless potential
the only thing we've been missing is the
will from Washington to finally build an
economy around you an economy that gives
you and your family a fighting chance to
get ahead
gives our country a fighting chance to
compete with the rest of the world
we can't get here thinking small
we have to think big
let me be clear
we need to prepare for 10 years down the
line that's what these bills do
both these bills spend out over 10 years
not in the first year
so if you take the infrastructure Bill
folks it's described as a 1.2 trillion
dollar bill
what that means is that of all those
Investments of Road Bridges high-speed
internet water everything else
all of it would be less than one half of
one percent of our economy each year
and it's all paid for
and they don't increase the debt because
they're paid for
by asking the very wealthy to begin
their pay their fair share
as a matter of fact significant portion
of this plan Cuts taxes for working
people
and best of all the cost of these bills
in terms of adding to the deficit is
zero zero zero
and I made a commitment when I wrote
These when I was running
no one making under four hundred
thousand dollars they will see a penny
in their taxes go up
that's why in the infrastructure Bill
there is no gas tax increase because
people make another 400 would have to
pay more it's simple
you're working here at this facility
for your spouse is a teacher a
firefighter there's no reason why
combined
why Millionaires and billionaires in
this country should be paying at a lower
tax rate than you do hear me again now
a lower tax rate
police officer a teacher
a union crane operator
and a nurse
they paid a higher tax rate
a higher tax rate
the significant portion of the major
corporations in America and the super
wealthy
look it isn't right
is it right that 55 of the largest
corporations in America in this country
and I come from the corporate capital of
the world
more people more corporations are
Incorporated in the state of those in
all every other state combined
but you know how much those 55 companies
I could go on more than that they made
over 40 billion dollars and they paid
zero
zero in federal income tax
how much did they pay
the number of billionaires and I forget
the exact number there are in America
have seen their wealth go up
collectively by one
trillion dollars
one trillion dollars
isn't fair
it needs to change look where can folks
understand that
that's why despite the tax the attacks
and misinformation
my plan has overwhelming support in the
polling data for the American people
they understand what's at stake they
understand that workers and families
have a better shot Americans have a
better shot I'm a capitalist I think you
should be able to go out and make a
million dollars or a billion but just
pay your fair share
join the crowd man wow they know that
this is about dignity and respect it's
about changing the power of God so the
economy works for you not just for those
at the very top
it's about building this economy from
the bottom up in the middle out that's
what I've done my entire career that's
why I ran for president
as I said I'm a capitalist
I think you should be able to make a lot
of money in America
but just pay your fair share whoa pay
your fair share
I took this agenda to the country
they said it was time to build an
economy that looks out from Scranton
Pennsylvania where I grew up as a kid
instead of looking down from Wall Street
an economy looks out from Howell
Michigan and towns like it all over
America that brings people from every
race background religion into the game
that's what and notwithstanding some of
the signs I saw come that's why 81
million Americans voted for me
the largest number notwithstanding the
science
clear majority
according
when they supported me
look
it's now time to deliver
let me close with this
the world's watching not a joke
the autocrats of the world believe the
world is moving so rapidly that
democracies can't generate consensus
quickly enough to bring their people
together to get things done
they think democracy is not not a joke
my meetings with Putin my meetings with
Xi Jinping and other leaders they truly
believe
that we can't compete in the 21st
century
because things are moving so fast
democracies take so much time
that they are so divided that they can't
get together in time to act
they believe they they they believe
they'll win they'll win the day and they
can dictate their way forward and leave
us behind they're betting not a joke
they're Betty for the first time we
won't respond to this inflection point
in history
and will fail to rise to the occasion
but you've heard me say it a lot of
times
it's never ever been a good bet to get
bench to bet against the American people
never right
look just look back a little ways
after World War II the United States did
what we're trying to do now invested in
the American people
to lead the world
at the time presidents in Congress of
both parties and Americans of all
political use stepped up
I'm not being sentimental here there was
racial discrimination was a fact of life
we're now deep rooted racism is in this
country we saw the clan marching here in
Hull Generations ago and again in recent
years
it's a never-ending battle but
think about what also unfolded in this
critical these critical decades
great protest movement some in the
nation was promised on of equity the GI
bill sent millions of veterans to
college
the federal government helped make home
ownership possible because it's the
vehicle by which people can generate
wealth
most of us who come from lower middle
class backgrounds that's how our parents
are able to generate any wealth the
investments in our home
for those who could previously only
dream of having the house
to call their own we invest in an
interstate highway system propelling our
economy into the future we invested in
the Space Race which led to huge strides
in technology
we invested in something called DARPA a
program within the federal government
that helped create the internet
folks we need to step up again
but the challenge of today is one of
economic competition
let's learn from that history
not because it was perfect because
Americans then did what we must do now
invest in ourselves to show the world
that American democracy works
and they give it half a chance there's
nothing not a single thing we can't
achieve when we do it together right I
know we can do this
and partially we can I've never been
more optimistic about this country than
I am right now we're going to restore
Faith pride and dignity the future of
this country
and we're going to pass both both of
these bills and start building this
economy to beat the competition and
deliver for work and Families thank you
may God bless you and may God protect
our troops let's get this done thank you
wow what a day
okay just kidding that's me playing the
song okay don't leave because I do have
other stuff to go through still okay so
I'm glad that people are still with us
um I I do want to say thank you to
Joseph yanover who just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com using the code
felony21 thank you Joseph also thanks to
everybody who subscribed via twitch
Prime and thank you to Taylor Hicks who
just signed up using the coupon code
felony21 on my website let's get to a
few other items here is Candace Owens
Candice Candice
um last night on uh uh Tucker Carlson's
show talking about what else George
Soros obviously this is the most
important thing Candace Owens is the
host of Candace she joins us tonight to
unravel this mystery so so here Candace
thanks so much for coming in so here
George church does not live in Austin
Texas don't think he ever has it's not
actually from this country originally
why would he want Austin Texas to have
fewer police officers on the street
that's a very good question and first
and foremost I'm so tired of the left
pretending like we've picked George
Shores to be our Boogeyman like that guy
but there goes the right talk why do
they all do that Alex Jones does it uh
who was the second sure George shoros
about George every time this man spends
money it it is towards an effort that is
going to undo American civilization
notoriously obviously he defunded black
lives matter all the writing all the
protests the open foundation he defunded
black lives matter Asian society which
which is his foundation gave money to
all these causes and you ask yourself
why he's a billionaire if he wanted to
help people or help black people he
doesn't need to give to Black lives
matter he can give it to tons of other
causes that actually do work to help
black people and don't destroy their
communities but here we have him again
in the same type of initiative going
against police officers and you ask
yourself why well you know if I'm going
to Fathom an idea or Theory as to why
he's doing this George Soros is a man
that made his money in investment so we
have to ask ourselves what is he doing
what is he invested in man is really
smart huh his Investments would go long
he would do well in his Investments if
America doesn't really exist it's weird
because like even if you take the
argument seriously
you and your your George let's take the
China example your George Soros or
George shoros as she says you want your
investments in China to do well so you
go let's defund the police in Austin
Texas because if Austin does poorly then
Texas does poorly the US does poorly it
gives an opportunity for China to do
well well we buy a whole bunch of the
stuff that China makes so if you destroy
Austin Texas the people who live in
Austin Texas now they lose their houses
whatever they don't buy the stuff China
makes like I'm I'm trying to take the
argument seriously but it's so painfully
stupid not to mention it seems easier
rather than investing in China and
trying to destroy the US in some weird
way to make your Chinese Investments do
well maybe just invest in the US and
don't try to destroy the U.S like it
doesn't even pass a a single sniff test
I've also said this to you many times in
the past Tucker and I want to say it
again I think the left is after more
than anything is the federalization of
the police force I've been saying this
over and over again yeah no that's an
authoritarian idea and it's the right
that wants that I'm sick of this crap
okay uh absolutely ridiculous next many
people many four people wrote to me and
said David
could you weigh in on what you think
about QT Cinderella's content
okay I don't know anything about QT
Cinderella other than I believe she was
part of the same POG Champs I was part
of uh a while back I've just pulled up a
random clip from her Clips Channel
uh this is QT Cinderella's honest
opinion on meeting xqc I have no idea
what it is I don't know if she's a game
streamer or IRL or what let's just take
a listen
you see
is so great
by the way is the eating on stream thing
a big thing is that a is that a thing
uh
working hard
on
like other people's streams too like he
doesn't just turn it on for his stream
like holy [ __ ] like what a sweet
sweet person and every single thing I
did he would say thank you for setting
that up thank you for setting that up
like he was so so everyone was so so
sweet and so so grateful but I was I was
genuinely genuinely I I haven't gotten
to spend as much time with X until this
week and he was insanely sweet he he
thanked me for everything and before we
left he was even like thank you so much
you're really really good at this he was
very very thoughtful and I I had no clue
and so funny
I didn't know X was funny
obviously he is X short for xqc like
it's already short you know is he's like
you know has so many viewers that's like
he's got to be funny who knew I didn't
know he was that funny he was so funny
okay all right I mean she seems nice
does that like what's the can anybody
explain like what
what's the content I guess is what I'm
saying
of QT Cinderella
this is the content but this is just
commenting about xqc
she's aggressive to other streamers
she it's salad and salad related
her content is about being Ludwig's
girlfriend variety huh okay well I don't
know if the four people who wanted me to
comment on QT Cinder I mean she seems
nice I I will chat with her if I mean I
don't know why I'm not saying she wants
to chat with me
if I came across uh QT Cinderella I
would have no problem chatting with her
I don't fully know what she does but she
seems very nice okay so that's that
um and then I did also want to show you
guys this this was something we got in
our Facebook inbox this morning
this is a gentleman named George who
wrote to me and said you keep calling
Trump supporters delusional I truly hope
that you open your eyes before the
Communist Democrat Nazi party a little
bit of a contradiction there
comes for you
Trump did not lose the 2020 election
actually he did George Trump did not
lose the 2020 election says George it
was part of a colors Revolution color
apostrophe s Revolution does anyone know
what that means
color apostrophe s Revolution
nobody knows okay it was part of a
colors Revolution educate yourself
educate your followers and open your
eyes otherwise you might find yourself
on that train just like the Jews
found himself on a Nazi train except
this time it won't be gas
it'll be an injection they call it a
vaccine dumbass big massive dumps
wow
that is like really really weaponized
uh
don't really know what to make of that
but that's that's pretty insane yeah
um wow
the hate mail is always crazy yeah
um Island guy said imagine logging in to
see the live show and the first thing
you see is Candace's face they like
bashing Soros because he's at the center
of an anti-semitic conspiracy theory
literally a continuation of the Jewish
question it seems to be that that's the
case yeah it definitely seems to be that
that's the case okay let me just finish
up with voicemails because I did start
voicemails and then we were interrupted
by Joseph R Biden Jr and different
things
um let's just listen to
a couple of voicemails we got a new one
from Eric from Mass
hey David it's Eric from Mass uh dude
you have uh what they call Stockholm
Syndrome
um they are abusing the [ __ ] out of you
thinking you wear masks making you do
this making you believing that everybody
needs to be vaccinated when the vaccines
worked
uh
you would only need to vaccinate
yourself to worry about yourself
I mean I don't know how long you know
you can
stick up for them but uh
when the truth comes out man I just I
really feel bad I was trying to get you
on the right side of this and okay so
anyway he really wants to help me
hey Pac-Man
so everyone until I tell you that um I
really appreciate you
um and then about like five zebras in my
life and
um
they're all
very like wonderful people
and I say stuff like I love you I'm like
wonderful stuff like that and
um
I was just wondering as far as like you
uh like traveling to Spain after living
and
[Music]
um
South America
um what exactly that's like is
I've just um encountered like Mexicans
here and of encountered Spanish and I
would just like
I felt like kinship with like Mexicans
yeah I'm not Mexican or Spanish so I
wouldn't really be able to comment on
that but I do always appreciate the
engagement and people who take the time
to call me and all of those things okay
reminder Tuesday October 19th at 6 PM
Eastern I will be doing a live Town Hall
it will only stream on the other YouTube
channel Pacman live youtube.com Pacman
live it won't stream on the main YouTube
channel it won't stream on Twitch it
won't stream on Facebook
it won't stream on random other twitch
or YouTube channels it will only be on
the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel
everybody's welcome to commit to Colin
everybody's welcome members will get
priorities so think about signing up at
joinpakman.com I'm so glad about
everybody who joined me today that's
going to do it for today's stream but
there will be another stream coming up
really really soon thanks everybody